>> GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIRMAN
BLUMENTHAL, RANKING MEMBER
BLACKBURN AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU.
MY NAME IS FRANCES HAUGEN.
I USED TO WORK AT FACEBOOK.
I JOINED FACEBOOK BECAUSE I
THINK FACEBOOK HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO BRING OUT THE BEST IN US, BUT
I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE I BELIEVE
FACEBOOK'S PRODUCTS HARM
CHILDREN, STOKE DIVISION, AND
WEAKEN OUR DEMOCRACY.
THE COMPANY'S LEADERSHIP KNOWS
HOW TO MAKE FACEBOOK AND
INSTAGRAM SAFER, BUT WON'T MAKE
THE NECESSARY CHANGES BECAUSE
THEY HAVE PUT THEIR ASTRONOMICAL
PROFITS BEFORE PEOPLE.
CONGRESSIONAL ACTION IS NEEDED.
THEY WON'T SOLVE THIS CRISIS
WITHOUT YOUR HELP.
YESTERDAY WE SAW FACEBOOK GET
TAKEN OFF THE INTERNET.
I DON'T KNOW WHY IT DOWN, BUT I
KNOW FOR MORE THAN FIVE HOURS,
IT WASN'T USED TO DEEPEN DIVIDES
AND MAKE YOUNG GIRLS AND WOMEN
FEEL BAD ABOUT THEIR BODIES.
IT ALSO MEANS THAT MILLIONS OF
SMALL BUSINESSES WEREN'T ABLE TO
REACH POTENTIAL CUSTOMERS AND
COUNTLESS PHOTOS OF NEW BABIES
WEREN'T JOYOUSLY CELEBRATED
AROUND THE WORLD.
I BELIEVE IN THE POTENTIAL OF
FACEBOOK.
WE CAN HAVE SOCIAL MEDIA WE
ENJOY THAT CONNECTS US WITHOUT
TEARING APART OUR DEMOCRACY,
PUTTING OUR CHILDREN IN DANGER
AND SEWING ETHNIC VIOLENCE
AROUND THE WORLD.
WE CAN DO BETTER.
I HAVE WORKED AS A PRODUCT
MANAGER AT LARGE TECH COMPANIES
SINCE 2006 INCLUDING GOOGLE,
PINTEREST AND FACEBOOK.
IT'S FOCUSED ON RECOMMENDATION
SYSTEMS LIKE THE ONE THAT POWERS
THE FACEBOOK NEWS FEED.
HAVING WORKED ON FOUR DIFFERENT
TYPE OF SOCIAL NETWORKS, I
UNDERSTAND HOW COMPLEX AND
NUANCED THESE PROBLEMS ARE.
HOWEVER, THE CHOICES BEING MADE
INSIDE OF FACEBOOK ARE
DISASTROUS.
FOR OUR CHILDREN, OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY, FOR OUR PRIVACY, AND FOR
OUR DEMOCRACY, AND THAT IS WHY
WE MUST DEMAND FACEBOOK MAKE
CHANGES.
DURING MY TIME AT FACEBOOK,
FIRST WORKING AS THE LEAD
PRODUCT MANAGER FOR CIVIC
MISINFORMATION AND LATER ON
COUNTERESPIONAGE, I SAW FACEBOOK
REPEATEDLY ENCOUNTER CONFLICTS
BETWEEN ITS OWN PROFITS AND OUR
SAFETY.
FACEBOOK CONSISTENTLY RESOLVED
THESE CONFLICTS IN FAVOR OF ITS
OWN PROFITS.
THE RESULT HAS BEEN MORE
DIVISION, MORE HARM, MORE LIES,
MORE THREATS, AND MORE COMBAT.
IN SOME CASES, THIS DANGEROUS
ONLINE TALK HAS LED TO ACTUAL
VIOLENCE THAT HARMS AND EVEN
KILLS PEOPLE.
THIS IS NOT SIMPLY A MATTER OF
CERTAIN SOCIAL MEDIA USERS BEING
ANGRY OR UNSTABLE OR ABOUT ONE
SIDE BEING RADICALIZED AGAINST
THE OTHER.
IT IS ABOUT FACEBOOK CHOOSING TO
GROW AT ALL COSTS, BECOMING AN
ALMOST TRILLION DOLLAR COMPANY
BY BUYING ITS PROFITS WITH OUR
SAFETY.
DURING MY TIME AT FACEBOOK, I
CAME TO REALIZE THE DEVASTATING
TRUTH.
ALMOST NO ONE OUTSIDE OF
FACEBOOK KNOWS WHAT HAPPENS
INSIDE OF FACEBOOK.
THE COMPANY INTENTIONALLY HIDES
VITAL INFORMATION FROM THE
PUBLIC, FROM THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT, AND FROM GOVERNMENTS
AROUND THE WORLD.
THE DOCUMENTS I HAVE PROVIDED TO
CONGRESS PROVE THAT FACEBOOK HAS
REPEATEDLY MISLED THE PUBLIC
ABOUT WHAT IT'S OWN RESEARCH
REVEALS ABOUT THE SAFETY OF
CHILDREN, THE EFFICACY OF ITS
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE SYSTEMS
AND ITS ROLE IN SPREADING
DIVISIVE AND EXTREME MESSAGES.
I CAME FORWARD BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT EVERY HUMAN BEING DESERVES
THE DIGNITY OF TRUTH.
THE SEVERITY OF THIS CRISIS
DEMANDS THAT WE BREAK OUT OF OUR
PREVIOUS REGULATORY FRAMES.
FACEBOOK WANTS TO TRICK YOU INTO
THINKING THAT PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS ALONE WILL BE
SUFFICIENT.
WHILE IMPORTANT, THESE WILL NOT
GET TO THE CORE OF THE ISSUE,
WHICH IS THAT NO ONE TRULY
UNDERSTANDS THE DESTRUCTIVE
CHOICES MADE BY FACEBOOK EXCEPT
FACEBOOK.
WE CAN AFFORD NOTHING LESS THAN
FULL TRANSPARENCY.
AS LONG AS FACEBOOK IS OPERATING
IN THE SHADOWS, HIDING ITS
RESEARCH FROM PUBLIC SCRUTINY,
IT IS UNACCOUNTABLE.
UNTIL THE INCENTIVES CHANGE,
FACEBOOK WILL NOT CHANGE.
LEFT ALONE, FACEBOOK WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE CHOICES THAT GO
AGAINST THE COMMON GOOD.
OUR COMMON GOOD.
WHEN WE REALIZE BIG TOBACCO WAS
HIDING THE HARMS IT CAUSED, THE
GOVERNMENT TOOK ACTION.
WHEN WE FIGURED OUT CARS WERE
SAFER WITH SEAT BELTS, THE
GOVERNMENT TOOK ACTION AND WHEN
WE LEARNED OPIOIDS WERE TAKING
LIVES, THE GOVERNMENT TOOK
ACTION.
TODAY, FACEBOOK SHAPES OUR
PERCEPTION OF THE WORLD BY
CHOOSING THE INFORMATION WE SEE.
EVEN THOSE WHO DON'T NEWS
FACEBOOK ARE IMPACTED BY THE
MAJORITY WHO DO.
A COMPANY WITH SUCH FRIGHTENING
INFLUENCE OVER PEOPLE, THEIR
THOUGHTS AND BEHAVIOR, NEEDS
REAL OVERSIGHT, BUT FACEBOOK'S
CLOSED DESIGN MEANS IT HAS NO
REAL OVERSIGHT.
ONLY FACEBOOK KNOWS HOW IT
PERSONALIZES YOUR FEED FOR YOU.
AT OTHER LARGE TECH COMPANIES
LIKE GOOGLE, ANY INDEPENDENT
RESEARCHER CAN DOWNLOAD FROM THE
INTERNET SEARCH RESULTS AND
WRITE PAPERS ABOUT WHAT THEY
FIND, BUT FACEBOOK HIDES BEHIND
WALLS THAT KEEPS RESEARCHERS AND
REGULATORS FROM UNDERSTANDING
THE TRUE DYNAMICS OF THEIR
SYSTEM.
FACEBOOK WILL TELL YOU PRIVACY
MEANS THEY CAN'T GIVE YOU DATA.
THIS IS NOT TRUE.
WHEN TOBACCO COMPANIES CLAIMED
THAT FILTERED CIGARETTES WERE
SAFER FOR CONSUMERS, SCIENTISTS
COULD INDEPENDENTLY INVALIDATE
THESE MARKETING MESSAGES AND
CONFIRM THAT IN FACT, THEY POSED
A GREATER THREAT TO HUMAN
HEALTH.
THE PUBLIC CANNOT DO THE SAME
WITH FACEBOOK.
WE ARE GIVEN NO OTHER OPTION
THAN TO TAKE THEIR MARKETING
MESSAGES ON BLIND FAITH.
NOT ONLY DOES THE COMPANY HIDE
MOST OF ITS OWN DATA, MY
DISCLOSURE HAS PROVED THAT WHEN
FACEBOOK IS DIRECTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS AS IMPORTANT AS HOW DO
YOU IMPACT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF OUR CHILDREN, THEY MISLEAD
AND THEY CHOOSE TO MISLEAD AND
MISDIRECT.
FACEBOOK HAS NOT EARNED OUR
BLIND FAITH.
THIS INABILITY TO SEE INTO
FACEBOOK'S ACTUAL SYSTEMS AND
CONFIRM HOW THEY WORK AS
COMMUNICATED IS LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
REGULATING CARS BY ONLY WATCHING
THEM DRIVE DOWN THE HIGHWAY.
TODAY, NO REGULATOR HAS A MENU
OF SOLUTIONS FOR HOW TO FIX
FACEBOOK BECAUSE FACEBOOK DIDN'T
WANT THEM TO KNOW ABOUT WHAT'S
CAUSING THE PROBLEMS.
OTHERWISE THERE WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN A NEED FOR A WHISTLEBLOWER.
HOW IS THE PUBLIC SUPPOSED TO
ASSESS IF FACEBOOK IS RESOLVING
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST IN A WAY
THAT IS ALIGNED WITH THE PUBLIC
GOOD IF THE PUBLIC HAS NO
VISIBILITY INTO HOW FACEBOOK
OPERATES?
THIS MUST CHANGE.
FACEBOOK WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE
THAT THE PROBLEMS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE UNSOLVABLE.
THEY WANT YOU TO BELIEVE IN
FALSE CHOICES.
THEY WANT YOU TO BELIEVE YOU
MUST CHOOSE BETWEEN A CONTENT
FULL OF DIVISIVE CONTENT.
THAT YOU MUST CHOOSE BETWEEN
PUBLIC OVERSIGHT OF FACEBOOK'S
CHOICES AND YOUR PERSONAL
PRIVACY.
THAT TO BE ABLE TO SHARE FUN
PHOTOS OF YOUR KIDS WITH OLD
FRIENDS, YOU MUST ALSO BE
INUNDATED WITH ANGER DRIVEN
VIRALTY.
THEY WANT YOU TO BELIEVE THIS IS
JUST PART OF THE DEAL.
I AM HERE TODAY TO TELL YOU
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THESE PROBLEMS ARE SOLVABLE.
A SAFER, FREE SPEECH RESPECTING
MORE ENJOYABLE SOCIAL MEDIA IS
POSSIBLE, BUT THERE'S ONE THING
THAT I HOPE EVERYONE TAKES AWAY
FROM THESE DISCLOSURES.
IT IS THAT FACEBOOK CAN CHANGE,
BUT IT'S CLEARLY NOT GOING TO DO
SO ON ITS OWN.
MY FEAR IS THAT WITHOUT ACTION,
DIVISIVE AND EXTREMIST BEHAVIORS
WE SEE TODAY ARE ONLY THE
BEGINNING.
WHAT WE SAW IN MYANMAR AND ARE
NOW SEEING IN ETHIOPIA ARE ONLY
THE OPENING CHAPTERS OF A STORY
SO TERRIFYING NO ONE WANTS TO
READ THE END OF IT.
CONGRESS CAN CHANGE THE RULES
THAT FACEBOOK PLAYS BY AND STOP
THE MANY HARMS IT IS NOW
CAUSING.
WE NOW KNOW THE TRUTH ABOUT
FACEBOOK'S DESTRUCTIVE IMPACT.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
SERIOUSNESS WHICH THE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS AND THE SECURITIES AND
EXCHANGE COMMISSION ARE
APPROACHING THESE ISSUES.
I CAME FORWARD AT GREAT PERSONAL
RISK BECAUSE I BELIEVE WE STILL
HAVE TIME TO ACT, BUT